[Music]
you loved season one of the witcher when
it came out now after watching 18 other
fantasy shows start your epic quest of
trying to remember anything from two
years ago i have absolutely no
recollection of any of these people
the witcher season two
geralt of rivia returns and while he's
still pretty grunty
[Music]
and almost
he's added a new weapon to his verbal
arsenal deep size
and since the law of surprise has a no
returns clause watch geralt play dead to
a girl who is either part bruxa
or just a normal teenage girl to be
honest
dive back into an awesome show about
badass characters and all the spin-off
bait they meet along the way as our
heroes journey to a helm's deep full of
witchers with one whole personality
split between them you're choosing to be
ignorant tasks aren't you including
vesemir the saddled man with a spin-off
backstory who's scared of another
conjunction maybe another conjunction
will come along a junction whose
function will be explored in another
spin-off and now everyone is concerned
with how they smell you both smell truly
awful even if you do smell like [ __ ] you
wreak your old horse i'm beginning to
smell like an elf guardian's ball sucks
to justify the spin-off set in the world
of deodorant ads
you could
i mean why stop there just green light
ncis blab again 90 day boar fiance real
housewives of nerf guard i mean i've got
some fluffy biscuits need butter in
gear up for a new adventure that drops
the non-linear storytelling of season
one in favor of a more straightforward
netflix series where the filler is more
obvious full of training
studying so what we'll be doing here
then studying monsters
yeah and an obstacle course that would
get yawned off of ninja warrior
because this season is less about the
monster of the week and more about
deepening relationships and character
growth sorry can't relate haven't grown
since the eighth grade now go find
something i used to doodle in my
notebook margins
oh yeah that's the stuff
weighed into the politics of middle poen
as you track the shifting allegiances
between uh see here where my notes
let's see stregabor frinde bear and
francilla of nilfgaard visimir
dikstra and philippa vridania and a
mirror of sentra
nailed it watch these bureaucrats
struggle through a plot line as boring
as the words elf migration crisis would
imply they need no other reason than the
ship of our ears and now the only hope
to bring peace between elves and men is
the widest blondest savior with magic
powers that come from having the purest
most untainted blood of all she's out of
blood there's a gene it keeps showing up
in central genealogy records eugenics
the cause of and solution to all the
continents problems
catch up with a hot cast of characters
who've either with or been by fire
[Music]
like tris the sweet nerdy girl who
always comes in second to girl's chaotic
goth x stay with me tonight
i'm sorry yes gear the bard who scored a
number one fantasy bob then went full
emo trying to break out of his sophomore
slob
yeah maybe some torture will help
go [ __ ] yourself yeah there we go that
one's going to my spotify wrap up daryl
it's trusty horse roach
gerald's other trusty horse roach
and jennifer who may have scored the
daenerys post season one my eyes are up
here contract but she's still trapped in
the same old story of boy meets girl
girl uses her magic to burn down a
forest boy believes girl has died girl
has an unfortunate encounter with
ancient witch in pocket universe before
losing powers boyd discovers girl may
sacrificed war to regain magic boy and
girl put off few to combat potential
apocalypse
so enjoy the smash hit show that still
has tons of rich and interesting source
material to explore and bloody epic
fight sequences to show off when it
chooses to so unless netflix gives the
show its patented three and done
treatment cowell's got plenty of witcher
money coming to keep his warhammer habit
fueled warhammer 40 000 that is my my
jam there are a lot of characters from
the warhammer versus the universe that i
want to be do you know warhammer at all
warmer forty thousand that kind of stuff
why is it when i talk about lesser
demons of nurgle my girlfriend ignores
me but when he does it i have to wipe
the chair down
starring
ah destiny's child
i'm just i'm just jenny from the berg i
can't do my magic and i need it cured
mentor the witch maker
dr ginge medicine woman
reince priebus believe science stop
stabbing yourself stop stabbing yourself
poet at the disco
little thumb
i don't i don't know what to do with my
nubs lenscrafters lisa frank edition if
this hutt's a walking don't come and
knock in what's that
[Applause]
[Music]
and you guys might not know this but i
consider myself a bit of a loner i tend
to think of myself as a one-man white
wolf back but when a hedgehog man
promised me siri i knew she was one of
my own and my wolf pack it grew by one
so there there were two of us in the
wolf pack i was alone at first in the
pack and siri joined in later and then
when adventuring introduced me to you
guys i thought wait a second could it be
and now i know for sure i just added two
more folks to my wolf back four of us
wolves running around the continent
together looking for monsters and baths
snow white flame and the gruntsman
oh the elves think they've got it tough
on the continent try being a baby
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what pair's great with this
witcher video another witcher video we
tracked every kill grunt and shirtless
scene to give you a full breakdown of
the witcher stats and geralt of rivia by
the numbers click the thumbnail on the
right to watch now
i would do anything for love but i won't
do that
prepare for trouble and make it double
you know i'm kind of a voiceover guy
myself
happy birthday to i don't know let's say
paige
and cut